[Musique]
le
les feuilles de vigne je ne peux pas
imaginer la cuisine sans les avoir nous
sommes en montérégie à la ferme bigard
de la chef turc missionnaire calme elle
y cultive entre autres des feuilles de
vigne quand elles sont fraîches comme
cela elles sont petites
touches voit la différence commencé
trois yeux les soyeux sont tellement
belles ouais en turquie en fait à
devient curieusement un arbre parce que
ça va sur le 3 le visage je sens comme
ça
on connaît bien usages qu'on fait du
raisin sur la vigne mais de ses feuilles
- le sarm a cuisiné par notre chef est
un classique culinaire à travers la
turquie la grèce en arménie et la
plupart des pays du moyen orient la
feuille de vigne farcies et est utilisé
comme maîtrisés c'est à dire en
accompagnement ou même en plat principal
dans ma région qui est la main à angers
ces vigies cru avec plants de fines
herbes et tomates écrasées dedans c'est
quand on va plus dans les régions qui
sont loin de la mer mais ils ont plus de
viande clsh de légumineuses
ici pour préparer mon serment on peut se
procurer des feuilles de vigne on peut
ce sont les dépliait ce serait ça ferait
des grandes feuilles j'imagine mais
elles sont très très grand dans ma
région ont choisi le plus petit quand
les feuilles commencent à grandir ça
veut dire qu'elles sont plus costauds
son goût est ce que ce serait
intéressant jamais probablement jamais
mangé mais pourquoi pas
là c'est très sale et c'était
directement dans la seconde où les
marques et yerga et cedar contiennent
100 mg de sodium par feuille d'où
l'importance de les blanchir car en plus
ses preuves sont sûrement plus coriaces
habituellement quand on prend des belles
feuilles d une soirée fraîche soit dans
son mur on les blanches et rapidement ça
serait vraiment pauvres sinon on en
devant l'om bouillant les feuilles
fraîches c'est vrai heureusement
instantané
on en a acheté des jeux farsi
mais c'est juste parce que le lit est
trop cuit donc ça devienne pas tout ce
n'est qu'à 6 du lait 1 on trouve des
feuilles de vigne farcies on conserve ou
fraîches elles aussi entre 93 cents et 2
dollars 74 200 g le hic c'est le taux
élevé en sodium le plus sali et dans la
marque salim avec 5 180 mg de sodium par
100 grammes ce qui représente la moitié
de la conserve
pour contourner ce problème vous pouvez
cueillir vous même vos feuilles de vigne
on en a beaucoup dans les ruelles à
montréal on envoie la sauce et
connaissait cet album comme
traître à bord la viticultrice véronique
lemieux connaît bien ses vignes qui
pousse dans les ruelles elle fait partie
de l'équipe du projet ville en ville de
montréal qui distribue des pieds de
biche aux résidents pour stimuler les
cultures urbaines
on a le houblon qui côtoie la vigne
parce que justement les gens qui veulent
recouvrir leurs clôtures ou avoir de
longues vont souvent avoir recours à ces
deux plantes l'a donc comment faire pour
différencier bon c'est sûr que le
houblon c'est comme quand on touche là
regardez ses collants donc c'est super
pour s'accrocher mais on va me va se
méprendre parfois moi ce que je dis dans
le fond aux gens c'est de vérifier s'ils
ont des fruits parce que s'il ya des
petits fruits une grappe en formation
mais l'on ne vraiment la confirmation
que c'est une ville lumière en regardant
des soupes accueille souvent sont
cachés les gravats la famille du betis
et c'est définitivement comestibles et
c'est sûr que prélever quelques feuilles
seller sa cause aucun problème leur à la
plante et ses vignes vierges sur nos
clôtures comestibles ou pas et les baies
qui posent sont toxiques et à partir de
cette tige il y a par exemple 5 feuilles
parfois six c'est pas une femme qui se
trouve au bout de la tige mais vraiment
un regroupement de plusieurs feux non ce
n'est pas comme estelle
attention vous cueillez vos feuilles de
vigne si vous êtes dans un environnement
dont vous ne connaissez pas le passé il
faut quand même faire attention la
présence des métaux lourds dans le seul
ou à d'autres éléments toxiques toutes
les contaminants se retrouvent dans les
feuilles et non dans les fruits
pour préparer ces serments lâchait fille
super cannes utilise ses feuilles
sauvages et les feuilles de vigne
l'emportent blanchi dans tous les cas
les feuilles doivent être des venues
que je vais commencer avec la farce vgp
au céleri les fines herbes comme il ya
la neige persiste ragone ainsi que du
basilic pourpre de l'union et de l'huile
de tournesol donc quand on les rôles
c'est pas trop serré parce qu'on sait
que le riz va prendre la place puis on
veut pas éclater les feuilles de vigne
et la version avec viande hachée
j'ai l'oignon rap est très faible odeur
percé on fait toujours un petit lit une
couche en dessous pour que les feuilles
de vigne farcies ne colle pas dans le
fond et j'ai ma sauce tomate de l'été
passé
je voulais tuer doucement c'est vraiment
jean-mi ajouté ça va prendre un peu près
une vingtaine de minutes de cuisson
pour commencer on goûte la version
feuille on peut au mieux le coup type
title un peu plus rêve de coriaces d'une
fait je vais agir devant la différence
avec vos feuilles sauvages
ah oui ouais vous voyez une tendreté le
drôle parce que l'acidité de la feuille
est là mais c'est pas agressant comme
ceux qui ont un saumur ouais c'est plus
citronnée oui juste assis nous c'est
vrai qu'on goûte plus la feuille
c'est vraiment si vous mettez la raison
qu'on aime les feuilles fraîches ah
c'est bon ça
[Musique]